wir bringen heute den frankfurter
weihnachtsbaum am römer einstellung
die hauptschwierigkeit liegt jetzt
erstmal an dem auspacken von dem braun
und im anschluss halt dass wir den baum
aufrichten können ohne dass wir
irgendwas beschädigen weil wir wollen
natürlich dass er in seiner natürlichen
beschaffenheit erhalten bleibt und wenn
ich irgendwo dann einen ast oder so
abbrechen und dann irgendwas künstliches
dran wieder dran setzen müssen
also es gab eigentlich bei uns überhaupt
keine verzögerung von unserer seite
offiziell war teil war abgeschlossen wir
konnten mit unseren arbeiten anfangen
der baum hat keine spitze verloren oder
so also hat alles tipptopp funktioniert